you may have been wondering why are we
talking about this why is scurvy
something that the long now foundation
the interval is going to do an event
about well there are a bunch of reasons
but this is one of them there's a real
website it is it is the the great
ambassador of scurvy awareness in the
21st century
that's Lyme strong don't don't miss type
it as something else it's Lyme strong
and so one day around the office I
actually wasn't in the room at the time
believe it or not but a number of long
now is finest Dan Linder if you're there
on the livestream hi Dan
and and and the other folks in the
office we're like well scurvy is this
actually this amazing long now story now
these guys are I have to say a little
bit tongue-in-cheek note that cats
wearing fruit helmets is only a couple
notches down from ways to prevent scurvy
so it may not be the most rigorous of
organizations but nonetheless it
inspired us and and and scurvy Awareness
Day was just a couple weeks ago on May
2nd so but when we think about scurvy we
are mostly thinking about history we're
thinking about this gentleman mr. James
Lind who you'll hear much more about and
his old-timey book how how old is the
scurvy stuff it's at a time when
actually apparently before the letter S
was invented which is pretty remarkable
but scurvy is still with us and that's
why we're really talking about it today
and they're there a number of long-term
themes that interests us that are a part
of this so here's here's where it is in
the u.s. six to eight percent now a lot
of times it's not diagnosed as scurvy
because believe it or not unless you've
got a doctor with a peg leg scurvy is
typically not the first diagnosis they
look at but a vitamin C deficiency which
is really what's at the core of scurvy
at the level that would be scurvy is
fairly common especially for folks
that are the poorest in our country and
in some cases male smokers who are up to
18% of male smokers have that kind of
vitamins efficiency and in fact there's
something called a cult scurvy which is
essentially scurvy but without some of
the more extreme physical physical
symptoms that you're gonna get it get a
glimpse of tonight and I don't know why
they don't use this word more because I
mean it's a cult scurvy but yeah so so
students a lot of times are in this kind
of condition and it's not surprising
because as you can see from this map
every state in the country
at least 30% of the population is not
eating a serving of fruit a day and it's
much worse in some area so so what's up
are why are these people not eating what
they should be are they are they stupid
are they just stupid
are they well no but but there there is
there there is a situation food deserts
are our reality we're healthy food is
largely unavailable and bad food or
unhealthy food is highly available and
very cheap and so the the phenomenon of
urban food deserts is definitely
contributing factor there are also
populations that are particularly at
risk for scurvy whether it's diagnosed
as scurvy or not and there have been
increasing diagnosis of scurvy those
numbers before I should have mentioned
her CDC numbers so these are these are
real studies lots of studies have been
done on this so populations that are
eating a monotonous diet for various
reasons institutions schools as we
mentioned hospitals prisoners soldiers
there are a lot of scenarios where folks
end up with it and so just a word about
refugee camps this shows a number of
different vitamin deficiencies that can
happen including vitamin A but the
vitamin C down here at the bottom up to
22 percent in this one that these are
numbers that a little bit older
in the 80s but certainly there are more
refugee camps larger refugee camps now
and the the challenges of feeding large
numbers of people is is even more
challenging today so what's amazing is
that the amount of vitamin C you can get
from a handful of ketchup packets is
really actually all that that they would
need to get out of the scurvy things so
this is our you know our practical
scurvy awareness and recipes aren't
gonna be this preachy okay no and but I
do have this last because once you start
hearing about scurvy you will start
wondering whether you are having enough
vitamin C so here's a handy chart that
shows you some of the foods and and
various vitamin C content you'll notice
when you see the things that have no
vitamin C how actually easy it would be
to to end up in a diet that doesn't have
vitamin C so watch out and you're gonna
get some tips even right here this
evening how you can up your vitamin C
intake without leaving this bar but so
we're gonna we're going to move on now
to our main and I don't have a drink
coming by chance do i okay well I'm
gonna do all right so our good friends
at odd salon who've we've done events
with here before have a tradition of in
there speaking series of doing a toast
at the end of each of these talks so
each of our speakers is going to do a
little toast and and so if you if you
have a drink please join me in this
toast so I want to before I bring our
next speaker up a toast to to all of us
and furthering scurvy awareness and to
three years of the interval thank you
for being here Cheers
mmm suffering bastard I recommend it
alright one last thing please hold your
questions
we are going to do a Q&A at the end of
the night I think we're gonna have time
to do that so we're also we a couple of
our speakers have books which we're
selling in the back and we're gonna
they're gonna sign at the end of the
night if you have them we're gonna start
off with James Nestor and following that
Jennifer Colio who's gonna tell us
something about how you can improve your
health I want to just mention so this is
our tenth talk of 2017 James was
actually our tenth speaker of all time
back in 2014 so give him a big round of
applause please mr. James Nestor all
right so when Michael wrote me a couple
weeks ago and asked if I wanted to do a
talk on scurvy I thought sure you know
I've written about science a bit written
about the ocean the sounds like fun
first thing I did was I went on Google
Images and I searched the term scurvy
victim so don't ever go on Google Images
and search the term scurvy victim trust
me on this so I apologize in advance for
what you're about to see here if you
have any problems you can blame him
Michael right there so I'm gonna do a
10-minute 4,000 year old history of
scurvy begins with exhaustion your
thoughts become scattered it's hard to
catch your breath eventually you start
bruising your gums start bleeding you
convulse you go blind and you die these
are the symptoms of scurvy the vitamin C
deficiency disease that by the 1700s
would claim 1 million sailors but scurvy
was around way before the great age of
sail and goes back to when humans were
roaming the earth so hunters and
gatherers didn't really get scurvy
because they were hunting and gathering
and if you're eating fresh you're eating
plenty of vitamin C the problems started
coming about around 13,000 years ago in
the agrarian revolution this is when we
learned to farm
go back there and when we learn to store
crops and wheat and the more we started
relying on crops and wheat the more
incidences of scurvy started coming up
around 3,500 BC this came out the Ebers
papyrus and the Egyptian ancients not
only diagnosed scurvy but they had a
cure for it they said eat raw onions if
you ate raw onions you'd have plenty of
vitamin C you wouldn't get scurvy and if
you had it you wouldn't have it for much
longer
but that ancient knowledge never passed
on to this guy Hippocrates in ancient
Greece he was the first in the West to
diagnose scurvy and he said that its
victims had feeded breath lacks gums and
hemorrhages from the nose
he said the condition was incurable and
would stay with victims until their
death now as everyone started moving
north the incidences of scurvy continued
and really blossomed because again we
were relying on stored foods preserved
foods the 13th century Crusaders had
rashes of massive rashes of scurvy
mostly during Lent when they abstained
from many of their normal foods and they
only ate eel meat as their primary
source of protein what they would do is
they would go to the surgeon barbers and
have their teeth removed so they could
masticate food a little better one of
the Crusaders said the barbers were
forced to cut away all the dead flesh
from the gums to enable the people to
eat their food well this of course
didn't work and thousands of Crusaders
died the Christians of course blamed the
evil heels so about a hundred years
later sailing technology really improved
vastly we were able to go longer and
stay at sea for months and months at a
time
Vasco da Gama in 1497 gathered a hundred
and sixty men and tried to find a sea
route to India what he found instead was
the first incidence
of sea scurvy a sailor on board wrote a
little poem of what it was like to be on
that ship a dread disease its rankling
horror shed and death star ravaged
through mine army spread never mine eyes
such dreary sight beheld ghastly the
mouth and gums enormous swelled an
instant putrid like a dead man's wound
poisoned with faded streams the air
round no sage physicians ever watchful
zeal no skillful surgeons gentle hand to
heal each dreamy mournful hour we gave
some brave companion to a foreign grave
so traitors in Africa immediately
noticed the problem with these men so
what did they do they gave them a bunch
of oranges a week later the men that
were still living healed miraculously of
course de Gama never acknowledged that
these heathens would have some sort of
cure for them he instead had his men
pray with their mouths full of their own
urine which I'm sure many of you did
this morning if you're anything like me
so of the hundred and sixty sailors that
set out on this voyage one hundred would
die of scurvy meanwhile in the West
jacques-cartier 16th century French
explorer was leading an expedition to
the eastern Canadian areas when a ship
got stuck in a frozen Inlet soon the
food started rotting things got really
bad really quickly Cartier wrote the
unknown sickness began to spread itself
amongst us after the strangest sought
that ever was heard or seen in so much
as some did lose all their strength and
could not stand on their feet then did
their legs swell their sinews shrink as
black as any coal with such infection
did the sickness spread itself into our
three ships that about the middle of
February of a hundred and ten persons
that were there were not ten whole so it
wasn't the cold air that was killing off
Cartier's men of course it was their
really
crappy rotten diet around the sixteenth
century almost all sailors didn't matter
if you were from Britain or Portugal or
France or whatever they were basically
eating the same thing and this was their
weekly ration four pounds of salted beef
seven pounds of biscuits two pounds of
salted pork a half pound of salted fish
a chunk of butter a chunk of cheese and
check this out one gallon of beer every
day it's a 12 pack of beer every day and
with that beer they ate their salted
meat and they included that with exactly
zero fruits and vegetables so it was a
diet that was just built for scurvy and
isn't Michael showed I mean you saw
those last five food groups that have
zero vitamin C that's what they were
eating so meanwhile in South Pacific
Polynesian sailors were spending weeks
and weeks at sea and going tremendous
distances but there were no written
instances of scurvy why is that because
their diet consisted of fruits
vegetables tubers fish and instead of
beer what did they have to drink coconut
water so just a couple of coconuts is
plenty of vitamin C to keep scurvy at
bay and to heal you if you have problems
but cardiod didn't know about that back
in the in the doldrums of Canada here he
was desperate to find a cure for his men
so he talked to the Iroquois Indians who
told him to use the branches of the
annada tree and to boil them so Cartier
did that he boiled them gave the steed
all of his men who would have guessed a
week later the men who were still alive
were totally healed so car D of course
never acknowledged that either he just
this is if these guys were pretty
stubborn by the mid 1700s there were
several dozen cures for scurvy that had
been documented over the past 3,000
years but British American and
Portuguese doctors either never got wind
of them which seems improbable or more
likely they refuse to prescribe them
because they were considered barbaric
unscientific or even worse
French so instead these doctors
prescribed their own cures they forced
patients to purge themselves with salt
water they rubbed mercury paste on to
open sores they bled them or check this
out they increased the sailors workload
and the belief that the disease was
caused by indolence and sloth
so nothing worked men kept dying until
this guy showed up this is James Lin
1747 he had a really noble idea he was
going to take all of these cures that
had been bandied around and actually
test them so he gathered a group of
sailors who had scurvy put them below
deck on the HMS Salisbury and treated
them with six different remedies and
watched what would happen to them for
two of those sailors he ordered them to
drink a quart of cider a day not bad
two other sailors drank sulfuric acid
three times a day that's a little worse
two more took spoonfuls of vinegar three
times a day the two worst off sailors
were put under a daily course of salt
water didn't do much then two lucky men
were administered massive doses of
nutmeg and if some of you may know I'm
just guessing here that if you take
massive doses of nutmeg you hallucinate
for like 72 hours so the final two were
given two oranges and one lemon every
day guess who recovered yes of course
the men who were given the oranges and
lemons they showed visible good results
right from the get-go and a week later
they were so well that they were
immediately put back to work so what
Lynn had just conducted of course was
the first clinical trial he wrote about
it in this a treatise of the scurvy
but Lynn himself was never really
accepted that lemons or oranges were the
single cure for scurvy instead he
subscribed to the medical opinion at the
time that scurvy had multiple causes
notably hard work bad water and bad diet
the treatise of scurvy actually had very
little impact when it was published not
a lot of people read it and fewer
followed it meanwhile by the end of the
18th century scurvy had become
responsible for more deaths at sea than
storms shipwrecks combat and all other
diseases combined so next up Jennifer is
gonna tell us what happened next thank
you all so much I am now going to kind
of weigh lay you with a like slight
diversionary tactic rather discussion of
scurvy in the form of cocktails and
really the history of scurvy is the
reason we have the gimlet it's it's
obviously I am a cup for anyone who
doesn't know me I'm a total giant
cocktail nerd history of all these
drinks and all the stuff is very
interesting to me so just to let you
know I'm gonna be discussing the gimlet
and then which is made with the original
gimlet is gin with Rose's lime cordial
I'm gonna get into that that being said
we don't have Rose's lime cordial here I
do have a gimlet on the menu you're
welcome to order it and if anyone does
not want to have alcohol I have prepared
a separate lime cordial that we're
making a bitter tricky with which is
basically a sweet lime soda with some
bitters in it okay so like I said we've
got Rose's lime right so this was start
this was created by a guy named Lachlan
Rose and this is his original patent it
was he patented the process by which he
preserved lime juice using sulfur and he
patented this in 1867 1867 is the same
year that the merchant shipping act
passed requiring sailors on merchant
ships to have lime rations for there to
be lime rations on on the ships now the
Navy had already had these these
protocols in place for decades but this
was the point at which the the
government said no no we need to make
sure that everyone who is sailing is
protected however the the interesting
thing about the 1867 point is that
sailors and and the government had known
about about citrus being a cure for
scurvy for quite some time
the original rations were lemons and
however the English colonizers around
the world people who had set up in like
the West Indies they started growing
limes there or they were cultivating
limes there so they lobbied the
government to change the rations from
lemons to limes which the government did
one lemons have more than twice the
amount of vitamin C that limes do so
there actually were some continuing
problems even even with this with enough
light with enough lime it's fine it's
not it definitely has vitamin C in it
it's just not quite as quite as potent
as the lemons so they changed they
changed this ration and like right then
right then
Lachlan Rose was ready with his patent
so the way that they that he preserves
lime is by taking the juice and and
exposing it to sulfur so how normally
did that was to put it all but that the
lime juice and sulfurous gas into an
airtight container and kind of moved it
around for a while until it absorbed the
sulfur then when you would open up the
container any sulfur that hadn't been
absorbed by the lime kind of off gasped
and you have this lime that was that
actually kept good for quite some time
didn't didn't oxidize in that way in the
way that obviously citrus juice can turn
really quickly before before Rose's lime
had started doing this they the lime
juice that was available on ships was
typically mixed with rum to a 15 percent
ABV so that's important later but just
remember that
so the Rose's lime there was no big
booming
you know market for non-alcoholic drinks
in the 1860s um but but however you did
he did set the stage for essentially
making soda syrups right okay another
thing that with Rose's lime is that it
is made by crushing whole fruit so one
of the characteristics of a lime cordial
is the oil content from that peel so
it's not just juice it is it that that
lime oil is important so we have to get
into a little bit of limes themselves so
Persian limes they're not this big in
real life that's a normal line the kind
of when we say lime this is what
everyone thinks of right the key lime
key limes okay Persian limes weren't
invented until 1895 so when you real
this historical stuff if you find all
cocktail books with cocktail recipes
that call for limes actually are very
few they mean key limes key limes differ
from Persian limes in a couple of
different ways they are both sweeter and
more acidic and higher in sorry they are
more acidic but they are higher in
aromatic compounds that we associate
with sweet foods like vanilla and
strawberries and that kind of thing
this essentially they are more intense
flavor so if you are to make old
old-style cocktails from home folks I'm
sure it's just me but and and things
call for limes really making it with key
limes is really how it was meant to be
and it actually has you know this
different chemical composition so the
the key limes originated in Persia our
growth overgrown all around the Middle
East and that is what people used for
limes right so a guy in California named
John T Barris in in 1895 hybridized the
the the Persian lime called
it's also called the bear slime you
sometimes see that B be a RSS and he
hybridized it to be larger and juicier
and harder and able to be transported
more easily key limes are you know more
fragile they're more delicate they go
Brown faster
so he he patented he he hybridized these
these limes nothing really took off
until a series of hurricanes in 1916 and
I started in 1926 and 1928 decimated
orchards in in Florida in in the Florida
Keys so it left a hole in the
marketplace for John T bears to to
promote his Persian line so so just to
be clear here key limes come from Persia
that's the Florida Keys Persian limes
come from California now we get into
into the gimlet itself the gimlet being
gin and Rose's lime or lime cordial
whatever Rose's lime was kind of the
only you know the only person with a you
say a horse and the race here so there's
a lot of theories of of the gimlet
cocktail kind of the biggest one that
people talk about it's Thomas G gimlet
he joined the Navy in 1879 he was a
surgeon and the two competing stories
one is that he was encouraging the
sailors to take their their lime juice
rations by mixing it with gin because
they would be far more likely to drink
different gin than lime juice um the
other one was that he was trying to
moderate consumption by kind of cutting
the gin with the lime juice in any case
he died in 1943 and by that time the
gimlet cocktail he become very popular
but it didn't mention that in his
obituary and he was also part of a book
called who was who for I was like 1941
to 1952 something like that and they
mentioned him they had a biography of
him and they did not mention this
cocktail so probably not probably not
that's where we got it um really when
you dig into cocktail history there's a
lot of fantastic stories and a lot of
times we don't really know so I spoil
alert we don't really know I'm just
telling you some theories there was also
a tool that
kind of looked like a corkscrew that was
used to open up the containers of lime
juice that were on the ships before
roses was was produced so this would
have been lime juice that was fortified
with really funky Jamaican pot still rum
to 15% if you mix that with gin
that's gross so I don't I don't think
that that is that that is it either um
the the Jillette cocktail Chicago style
I really actually like kind of any
mention of this book this is kind of
remarkable this guy Tom Bullock who is
out of st. Louis the first African
American to ever publish a cocktail book
so he was a prominent bartender in 1917
and st. Louis anyways he had a Gillett
cocktail which was old Tom gin which was
kind of a mild slightly sweet gin fresh
lime juice and sugar and that's what we
call today a daiquiri right the gimlet
being specifically reserved for gin with
lime cordial and but you know Gillette
pretty similar kind of similar and then
the in the Savoy cocktail book there's
two mentions the gimlet which is very
similar to the to the the Gillette
cocktail except it has soda in it so it
is actually that one doesn't have sugar
so it really is a lime Rickey so you've
got gin you've got lime juice and you've
got soda water and that is traditionally
what a what a Rickey is without the
without the sweetener and then they also
do publish a gimlet cocktail so now here
we're seeing there's similar names but
not exactly the same thing and they have
a gimlet and that does specify equal
parts plymouth gin and roses lime
cordial first actual printing that we
know of of the real of the like true
recipe but obviously in 1930 not the
first occurrence Rose's lime so Rose's
lime today you make you have you may
have seen many of these versions there
are so many versions around the world in
the UK they sell things called lime
cordial so we've got this one here lime
lime juice cordial this one is lime
cordial mixer this one's also lime juice
Vergil depending on where you are in the
world there's different bottlings here
in the US we they sell it as sweetened
lime juice from concentrate I for a
while I thought that it was because
cordial in the u.s. specifically refers
to alcoholic things but apparently I'm
wrong you can make a non-alcoholic syrup
and call it a cordial which is odd that
not that not more bartenders do that but
regardless the u.s. uses high fructose
corn syrup for the its own by its own by
Schweppes now which is Cadbury big giant
giant company it was actually part of
the big kind of conglomerate company
that has owned in the past Heinz
that's like a1 steak sauce Stoli I
believe they owned a bottle cocktail
company called cube line that sold
bottled bottled daiquiris with lime
cordial which is really not not a
daiquiri anyways the right now if you go
to a liquor store and you buy a bottle
of Rose's lime juice the ingredients in
order are water high fructose corn syrup
lime juice concentrate sodium
metabisulfite preservative number 223
natural flavors and blue number one this
is a reason why you don't see Rose's
lime in good bars despite the fact that
it is the thing in a in a gimlet the
problem is is that that wasn't the way
that it was back when the drink was
first drunk so we do different things
now to kind of compensate for that kind
of stuff we have a gimlet here obviously
this is I like to say that this is
probably the best drink I've ever
created which is hilarious because I
obviously didn't create it but it but I
I feel like I perfected it so I took who
the important parts of lime cordial
which is the oils from appeals and the
juice and then having it be that
preserved kind of thing so you've got a
little bit of that a little bit of that
funk and a little bit of that almost
jammy quality to it and so I we we take
the we take high-proof Plymouth Navy
strength Plymouth and we zest a bunch of
limes soak the zest
in the Plymouth and then we make a syrup
with the lime juice and sugar let that
cool combine the two after we've
strained out that zest and let it sit
for a couple of days until it separates
and then we go through a long and
painstaking filtration process but one
of the things that I like so much about
this drink is that when we stir it over
ice thereby diluting it it glows it has
this like nice little lush appearance to
it it's the same reason that absinthe
Lucia's when you have this high proof
spirit it does have essential oils in it
and when you bring it down and proof by
the dilution those oils solution those
oil molecules are coming out of solution
and into suspension which creates a
slight kind of milky glow to it so the
gimlet has been mentioned many times in
[Music]
in in in different works of art that I
think are really kind of funny because a
lot of times the gimlet is seen as a
drink of cowards or weak people in yeah
in the short happy life of Francis
mccomber or its Hemingway they there's a
group of hunters and they have a very
shameful horrible hunt and unsuccessful
and they go and they drink gimlets in
their shape in England Gary Glen Ross
the gimlet is what a weak-willed
customer is drinking when he's getting
the hard sell Edward Albee this one is
pretty bad so in Who's Afraid of
Virginia Woolf and read this so then
Karen the main character is talking
about his wife and he says back when I
was courting Martha she'd ordered the
damnedest things we'd go into a bar you
know a bar a whiskey beer and bourbon
bar and what'd she do would be she'd
screw up her face think real hard and
come up with brandy Alexander's creme de
cacao frappes gimlets flaming punch
bowls
seven-layer liqueur things but the years
have brought to Martha a sense of
essentials the knowledge that cream is
for coffee lime juice for pies and
alcohol pure and simple here you are
angel for the pure and simple
lovely and then in with Raymond Chandler
it kind of gets slightly slightly
redeemed and the two main characters are
at a bar and one of them sets the other
they don't know how to make them here
what they call a gimlet is just some
lime or lemon and gin with a dash of
sugar and bitters a real gimlet it's
half gin and half Rose's lime juice and
nothing else
it beats martinis Hollow and then for
anyone who doesn't drink or who wants to
have a gimlet like experience without
without Rose's lime now this is Rose's
lime marmalade slightly more natural
very hard to find here you can find
enough I knit like a British grocery
store a place but really any kind of
marmalade is made with both the juice
and the peels so you're going to get the
oils from the peels in there and the way
I handle that and cocktails is I take
equal parts of marmalade and hot water
and you can put it on a stove or if the
water is already boiling you just stir
it until all the goopy bits of the
marmalade are dissolved and then you
strain it out and you have what is very
close to a cordial that you can then use
in cocktails so that is actually what
we're using in the non-alcoholic bitter
drinky that we have behind the bar and
[Music]
yeah that is that's that's all I got so
thank you I'm having a martini by the
way I know I know people are gonna ask I
drink my martinis this is Farallon I
play I am not I'm not like a one gin
woman Farallon I drink my martinis wet
up with the twist
wet means because vermouth is delicious
anyway so cheers to some sort of scurvy
remedy not being so miserable
[Applause]
Thank You Jennifer and and it should be
noted that our gimlet actually has a
wired video dedicated well half dated it
also - are you spicing other things so
look at that look that up and we'll post
that on our social so forth so thank you
to our great speakers so far we have two
more speakers our next speaker Kara
Plutonia
in the back we have the technology and I
should say the the the long now clock
and and Alexander is our executive
director feature in her book it's all
about different human senses and other
perceptions of the perception of time is
the chapter in which we feature what's
what's interesting is it has to be
almost exactly three years ago because
the interval was under construction when
you were doing that interview and you
talked about Jen training the staff here
so it's kind of this perfect connection
going on here to do that but just a
quick reminder that Jen and all of our
speakers are gonna be sticking around so
you can ask her more questions if you
didn't catch something in that recipe
etc just keep it in mind cuz I'm not
sure if we'll have time for our
questions tonight so we're gonna have
Cara with an insulting history and then
Jamie Jones who spoke just earlier this
year talking about some evolutionary
paradoxes for you so a big round of
applause for Kara please everyone okay
hello thank you yeah when I was writing
my book Sandra was actually putting the
planets in the Ori that's right behind
you this place was just opening so okay
so I am NOT a linguist or a literary
expert I'm a science reporter I teach at
UC Berkeley it's the end of the semester
and my connection to the subject matter
is that I probably have scurvy at this
point so so when you think of a scurvy
as an insult
you probably think of these guys and
it's true whose scurvy very bad for
pirates and all sailors but I'm here to
argue that you should probably think of
this
so Shakespeare lived right smack in the
middle of the seafaring scurvy epidemic
he was alive between 1564 and year 1616
so during his lifetime Admiral Richard
Hawkins his fellow Brit figured out the
lemons and the Lions trick but is gonna
be another 150 years before James Lind
kind of put it to the test and
scientifically proved that it worked so
scurvy remained a horrifying gross
disgusting disease which made it an
awesome insult so Shakespeare wasn't the
first guy and he wasn't the only guy
he's scurvy as an insult but he was the
most elegant the most famous and
Shakespeare was an artful and prolific
insult her anyway so today you can go
online and you can look up there's
Shakespeare insult generators and if you
would prefer the analog version
scholastic you know the publisher that
makes books for kids they have a
Shakespeare insult kit which is kind of
like you take a insulting noun from
column one and you put it with a
scandalous adjective from college column
two and that somehow teaches you
literature appreciation there's there's
actually an entire dictionary it's
called Shakespeare's insults a pragmatic
dictionary the author her name is
Natalie VN Guerin and she points out
that many of the words that Shakespeare
uses as insults aren't derogatory on
their own the insulting this kind of
depends on tone and on context so she
writes insults only exist when they are
interpreted and what she means is like
you can in you can lovingly refer to
somebody as a knucklehead right and you
can and Shakespeare apparently did use
otherwise adorable words like otter as
an insult so basically whether a word
has perceived as a tenderness or or as
an insult depends on how hard you are
flinging it at someone so Shakespeare
used scurvy 25 times in in his plays
mostly the good ones he did not use it
in the love sonnets I checked I I
recommend open source Shakespeare org to
you if you would like to look of any of
Shakespeare's insults and how he deploys
them so here it is in King Lear and this
is in one of the semi demented Kings
kind of
rambling moments in which he never led
to us manages to score some really good
insult points so he writes get the glass
eyes and like a scurvy politician seemed
to see the things that thou dost not and
here it is in a fellow and this is where
the maid amelia uses it to talk smack
about the person who is trying to
convince a fellow that his wife is
cheating on him so she writes the more
meaning othello is abused by some most
villainous knave some base notorious
knave some scurvy fellow now little does
she know that that person happens to be
her husband the the villainous Iago and
she knows even less that he is standing
right behind her so in in Romeo and
Juliet the nurse who's Juliet's
chaperone uses it to scold some of young
Juliet's suitors about basically loving
her and leaving her so she says now a
for god I am so vexed that every part of
me Quivers the scurvy knave let me tell
you should you lead her into a fool's
paradise if you should double deal with
her truly it were an ill thing to be
offered and finally in the tempest he
actually puts it in the words of a
drunken sailor which is where it should
be right so this is Stephano who
believes he is a shipwrecked on a
magical Island and he sings this he says
I shall no more to see to see here I
shall die ashore this is a very scurvy
tune to sing at a man's funeral well
here's my comfort many drinks so now I'm
not a language expert but even I noticed
that when you use scurvy this way it
undergoes two linguistic transformations
so the first thing is that it goes from
being a noun to being an adjective
describes something right and modify
something so it's like a scurvy dog or a
scurvy rascal and the second thing is
that it moves into becoming a metaphor
right so it's no longer about a physical
ailment it's about a moral failing and
today in our dictionary this is usually
the first definition so this is my
Webster's dictionary and you can see it
means low mean vile or contemptible so
now I should point out that scurvy is by
no means Shakespeare's only medical
insult he's got some other choice cuts
like infectious puking spleen II yeasty
boil brained dizzy eyed fat kid need
milk-livered and canker-blossom and in
the modern day we still use diseases as
insulting imagery so words like you
might have called something a cancer or
a plague use the term sickening if
you're British you might have said
bloody lousy or SCAP which in
Shakespeare's time in the 1500s was
essentially a synonym for kind of a
scurvy rascal but in the 1700s meant to
somebody who crossed the picket line
during a strike so what makes disease
such a powerful insult
well I'm not an animal just as you know
but when I wrote a book about bio
hacking and sensory perception I learned
a lot about how finely tuned your brain
is for danger
and one of your biggest defences against
biological danger which is germs is
discussed right
and so disgust is at least partly
learned and that you have to learn
something about what it is to avoid if
you've ever watched a baby pick up a
band-aid you know that those protocols
are not all hardwired right so we are
cute about what shits that's your brain
for analogy not an actual science so
we're we're cute about what should
disgust us in a couple of ways so one is
that it's learned through your sense of
smell and taste but basically by things
that you've had bad experiences with so
if you've had a run-in with an
unfortunate shrimp that you're gonna be
off shrimp for a while right um we're
all so unnerved by a face that doesn't
look like a face so uh or doesn't look
entirely like a face so a healthy face
should be symmetrical and proportional
and when it's not that's an indicator to
us either of a disease or it's an
indicator that's that something is dead
that it's rotting right and either way
your brain goes oh my god there's a
pathogen whatever got him could get me
so I need to get away this is the origin
of the uncanny valley which you have
probably all heard of before the idea
that we like images of human faces that
are photorealistic so the kind of the
curve goes up as things get more
humanoid and then it drops when things
get close to photorealistic but not
quite and then
they go up again when they're totally
realistic so this is not the original
drawing of the uncanny valley by
Masahiro mori this is a reworking that I
found on Wikimedia Commons by a guy or
lady I know only as s Marie and Chester
but whoever this person is is a genius
because they've amended the original to
add corpse which is germane to our point
and zombie right there at the love way
so finally the other way we learn what
to avoid is by looking at other people's
reactions so there is a universally
recognized disgust face that kind of we
automatically do when we eat something
that's spoiled or the or bitter so
Rachael Hearst who's a researcher on
that your sense of smell wrote a book
called that's disgusting that is all
about this and she describes that face
this way
she said we close our body especially
our face off from invasion which is why
your upper lip retracts you're no
scrunches up and your eyes squints and
if it's really bad you might COFF you
might spit you would stick out your
tongue you might even throw up you're
trying to expel the bad thing from your
body and when you see somebody doing
this you know to avoid whatever it is
that they just ate or touched and so
when physical wretchedness stands in for
moral wretchedness it triggers the same
feeling which is discussed in the same
reaction which is avoidance and the
facial cues we use for social rejection
or something that disgusts us morally
are the same you squint your face you
sneer you you stick out your tongue you
make fake gagging motions and all of
these are signals of social contempt and
of a person or a behavior that we should
avoid
and so insults serves this purpose to
this signal contempt and they assert
your own social status while they
diminish somebody else's there's
actually a little branch of psychology
called maledicte ology which is the
study of swearing and and cursing and
when you look through they kind of
online dictionaries and lists of swear
words that these guys have curated and I
have you'll see that diseases are a top
source for insults but they're not the
only ones the other ones are sex pop
your mama and your God and you get a
better reaction when you combine the
sacred in the revolting for best effects
so and insults about your mama is bad
and insults about your mama and sex is
worse when you mix that with disease or
defecation and it's even worse and when
you combine it with God its blasphemy so
so now disease metaphors might be very
useful in terms of evolutionary biology
and keeping us safe from infection but
they're not very well nice right and
we're becoming increasingly aware of how
not nice some of them are because of the
way that the language is changing so a
lot of the old health related insults
are now considered really awful and
upsetting because they mock people with
disabilities our mental health so today
we would teach kids not to say things
like crazy or schizo or lame or [ __ ]
right but you know even just a short
while ago when we were growing up these
were very common slurs left over from a
time when these conditions were
considered scary or disgusting and we
had less empathy and respect for people
who have them and let's not forget that
a lot of things that are kind of
marketed to us as a health slur is
actually based on a racial or ethnic
stereotype which actually brings us back
to scurvy
so once the Brits figured out the citrus
trick the sailors and the Caribbean
started to put as you heard before lime
into their into their beer because it
was cheap and limes where lines were
available right um and so limey became
an ethnic insult for the Brits right now
as you also know it turned out lime
juice did not work so hot by 1860 the
disease had actually rebounded because
lime juice wasn't as good as lemon juice
and speaking of things that didn't work
in Caribbean slang there's a word called
liming which means basically to loiter
or to hang out as though one is a
British sailor with nothing better to do
until light under the trees or to go to
the bars and drink beer so alright oh I
forgot to show you my not historic photo
of lime and beer they did not have
Schlitz okay so a last point so we know
that diseases can become squares but
hence wearing make you healthier and the
answer is May
there is a researcher named Richard
Stevens at Keele University in the UK
who studies basically the health effects
of swearing so in 2011 he did a study
where he had people stick their hands in
a bucket of ice-cold water and he found
that people who were allowed to swear
could hold their hand in the bucket of
water 40 seconds longer than people who
had to yell a neutral word and yes and
in a paper published this year he
followed up and he had people either
ride an exercise bicycle or to a
handgrip test either while swearing or
yelling a neutral world word and long
behold the swearers were stronger in
both exercises yeah so and it's not
clear why it happens he thought it was
because it activates your your
fight-or-flight response and that it
would increase your heart rate but it
turned out it's not actually doing that
so now he thinks it might be something
simpler like swearing creates a
distraction or it makes you love
self-conscious you're paying less
attention to your pain so so that's it
for me and now thank you alright
so alright purchased so to the bard well
here's to your comfort drink
[Applause]
caris a tough act to follow but I will
do my best
I wore my grant-writing t-shirt today I
I came from the office and I was writing
grants today so I'm in a hustling mood
and I have my very academic looking
title slide so I'm gonna talk today
about why do we why are we at risk for
getting scurvy it seems like a weird
thing it's this awful disease that
killed so many sailors and has killed so
many people worldwide and apparently 8%
of Americans have scurvy who knew why is
it that we're vulnerable to getting
scurvy birds do it
trees do it
lampreys in the sea do it let's do it
let's biosynthesize vitamin C we don't
do this we would not get scurvy if we
could synthesize vitamin C all these
other vertebrates and for Christ's sake
pretty much all of higher life
synthesizes vitamin C we do not okay so
there's a bit of a mystery here
what is vitamin C good for it's good for
lots of things it's the most important
antioxidant that we have dietarily and
we have it dietarily because we don't
synthesize it it's an antioxidant which
cleanses a system of reactive oxygen
species free radicals as they're
frequently known and these things
destroy cell membranes and they induce
genetic mutations these are the major
causes of Aging
okay so that by taking in more of the
the vitamin C the antioxidant we age
less we reduce our the oxidative damage
that causes us to age it's in every
tissue and it's in every cell type it's
really important this guy here I just
love this picture
Albert Jean Georgie
he is a Hungarian physiologist who
figured out who he I saluted vitamin C
and this is this portrait for his Nobel
Prize which he won in 1937 and I just
loved the idea for Albert or professor
Yogi's and Gorky we're gonna take your
picture he's like wait let me go get my
cigar right this is like this is these
guys were medical scientists so he found
this in 1937 he elucidated the citrus
cycle and found it in in we've
subsequently found it in all sorts of
mother nature's creatures here I have a
phylogenetic relationship sees in the
evolutionary relationships it's like a
genealogy of mammals and all the ones
that are in black produce their own
vitamin C all the ones in red don't and
we can see that this isn't somehow some
sort of quirk of history right it's not
like everybody's in the same lineage who
doesn't produce vitamin C there are
three groups of mammals human twork
humans and and other anthropoid primates
okay but not lemurs and the
strepsirhines so not all primates have
lost vitamin c synthesis bats including
fruit bats and insectivores bat bats and
guinea pigs as far as I know there are
no other rodents I can't do it guinea
pigs
alone so we have bats we have guinea
pigs and we have humans chimpanzees this
is a chimp in the cavalli National Park
in Uganda I watched this particular
chimp eat I'd say a thousand of these
fruits in one day they'd go to town
there ripe fruit specialists and when
they eat fruit they eat a lot of fruit
they are in no danger of ever having
scurvy gorillas this is this is quick
tonda he lives in Rwanda I strongly
recommend if you ever have an
opportunity to go to Rwanda it's the
most amazing country and go gorilla
trekking and you'll go spend an hour
with these guys and they literally live
in a salad bowl okay they literally live
in a sellable and and and you can eat
some of the things that they they don't
leaves the mostly piff's of the stems of
plants and if you take a bite of them
you'll find they're very peppery and
they're very sour right so there's just
a ton of it and see he's never gonna get
scurvy we get scurvy and it's gross
scurvy is a very old timey disease as
we've been introduced to another very
old timey disease that I have a picture
of here is gout which is related to the
formation how many people that have
gouty yeah I do a little bit yeah it's
it's caused it's a very painful
condition when uric acid forms crystals
in your joints it's an arthritic
condition and it hurts like hell and it
was associated with this sort of high
life of 18th century Europe this sort of
decadent culture and here's a devil
putting a poker on this poor guy's foot
right and I don't have time to go into
it but it turns out that the thing that
makes us vulnerable for forego is very
similar to the thing that makes us
vulnerable for vitamin C so I think that
there is actually a story that links
these two things together that's just a
teaser because I don't have time to talk
about it so a little comparative biology
big animals live longer than small ones
this is just a plot or logarithms of
maximum lifespan and body mass for 1,400
mammals primates live longer than
mammals in general basically everybody
except for this poor guy is above the
mammalian line and that goes for little
cute things like mouse lemurs fit in the
palm of my hand big things like gorillas
that's the biggest of the primates and
humans and this is Emma Moreno who died
last month in in April she's the oldest
human being with a recorded birthday she
was a hundred and seventeen and a
hundred and thirty three days she's the
last known human to have been born in
the nineteenth century who died
so we're remarkably long-lived primates
in general or long-lived humans are
particularly long-lived and it just in
case you think that's like an artifact
of modern medicine
the modal age of death of
hunter-gatherers living in the Kalahari
Desert
the Bushmen the Kung Bushmen is seventy
right so they have a life expectancy at
Birth of about thirty-five but that's
because so many five-year-olds died or
five and unders
if you survive to your fifth birthday
you're probably gonna survive to your
65th birthday so long lifespan is is a
part you know threescore in ten years as
the Bible tells us this is part of human
biology this other group bats live a
long time
they're long-lived little critters and
bear in mind that most dots weigh 50
grams right there down at the far end of
this the far left end of this plot that
includes the adorable bumblebee bat and
the baby not so adorable depending on
how you feel about it flying fox
[Music]
so both humans and and the other
anthropoid primates and bats have taken
one of two different strategies that you
can take for getting by in a highly
variable world the one thing so this is
a picture of temperature over the last
two million years and one way you can
deal with this so it goes up and down
what that's the only reason it sits on
there one reason one way you can deal
with of a highly variable environment is
you try to cram all your reproduction in
to the good periods in between the bad
periods right and that's what rodents do
that's what lots of insects do right
that's what little things with big
reproductive rates do the other thing
you can do is you can spread your
reproduction out and you can try to
average over the good and bad times and
that's what humans do and that's what
bats do ok so there's been enormous
selection for long lifespan in primates
humans in particular and bats this is a
little brown dot genus myotis it's a
common bat of North America this guy who
lives 42 years 70 grams fits easily in
my hand I could probably fit two of them
in my hand so just to give you a sense
of how
crazy long lived they are I'm gonna plot
in little brown bat equivalents the
lifespan of three different mammals a
little brown bat lives one little brown
bat the ears in order to get that amount
of lifespan you would need to have four
manatee lifespans or six Mongolian
gazelle lifespans
that's a critter that's this big right
the little brown Bela fits in my hand
these are very long-lived things okay
and so my point is basically that that
long lifespan is associated with the
inability to synthesize vitamin C all
the mammals who have lost the ability to
synthesize vitamin C which we do in our
livers well the lucky ones of us who can
do it in our livers we've all lost the
same step in the synthetic pathway it's
called gulo and and and it's the last
step that produces l a-- score of 8
which is ascorbic acid which is vitamin
C and now remember vitamin C its primary
role it's an antioxidant right it scoops
up free radicals reactive oxygen species
it cleans them up but in order to
produce it this step guess what it
produces hydrogen peroxide a very strong
oxidizing agent perhaps some of you have
had this experience of pouring hydrogen
peroxide on to a cut the same thing that
happens on the outside happens on the
inside it destroys cells it induces
mutations this is why doctors say this
is probably not the best way to clean a
cut right because it's it's it actually
damages tissues so if you are a thing
that needs to live a long time because
you're trying to average over this super
variable environment and get get by in a
variable world and you can get your
vitamin C dietarily
then the selection on you know keeping
that that metabolic pathway is greatly
relaxed you can get away with it most
primates can get away with it right you
long lived things we we've had this
strong selection for the lack of vitamin
C synthesis and incidentally for uric
acid the thing that puts us at risk of
gout for most primates and probably most
humans right as James pointed out that
if you're a hunter-gatherer you're
really not in danger of not getting
enough vitamin C but as soon as you
colonize these new areas that deserts
the oceans the Arctic you put yourself
at danger because we can't synthesize it
in our damn livers guinea pigs are
harder and I'm just gonna end by saying
that as rodents go guinea pigs are
actually pretty long-lived a guinea pig
can live for 12 years and there's
actually a slightly more complicated
story than the one I've told you today
that the guinea pigs fit into and I
think it actually is quite consistent
but they're not gonna set any any
lifespan records although as rodents go
they do pretty well so that's all I've
got
thanks oh yeah I'm gonna keep it simple
to the bats
[Applause]
so so with apologies time is caught us a
bit so we're not gonna have time for Q&A
but they're all gonna stick around each
one of them has a million more stories I
want to say one quick thing which is as
as sort of came out none of these are
experience score biologists I want to
all these guys did an amazing job of
coming up with some incredible material
for this all kind of adjacent to your
expertise but really we've won the last
round of applause to appreciate these
guys for the quick study nature of their
talks tonight
[Applause]
[Music]